i kind of like this clip not because fox
news anchor chris wallace is some huge
critic of fox news
while being on fox news but because it's
a thinly veiled shot at some of the
nonsense that's been regurgitated by fox
news
since the election including remember
this story of right-wingers going after
dr jill biden because
she's being called doctor without being
a medical doctor so let's look at this
clip from sunday's interview
where chris wallace interviewed incoming
white house press secretary jen
sackey let's take a look at the clip
finally
there has been some criticism recently
from conservatives including some
conservatives on fox news
about the fact that first lady to be
jill biden goes by
the title doctor i i wonder
what is the biden's reaction to that
especially given the fact that so
many people over the years
i think of dr henry kissinger the
reverend dr
martin luther king have gone by the
title doctor even though they're not
medical doctors and nobody seems to have
made a fuss about that that's
exactly right chris it's a bit
perplexing to me and i'm sure to
millions of americans that
with thousands of people dying every day
of covid millions out of work
that anyone wake up in the morning and
decide that the focus they need to have
the way they contribute to society that
day is to
question whether or not dr jill biden
someone who's still teaching who has a
phd in education should be called a
doctor or not of course she should
as anyone who works through that
challenging process of getting a phd
it's a
it's a really silly sexist and absurd uh
conversation that's happening a bit in
society and i appreciate you asking me
about it
jen thank you thanks for your time the
criticism
from conservatives on fox news chris
wallace
says now as i said on the stream that i
did yesterday
we have a very backwards situation right
now
where people without any college degrees
or people with bachelor's degrees in
areas that have nothing to do with
education
are evaluating the merits of jill
biden's doctoral thesis
her dissertation about education random
right-wing journalists with no
experience in ed policy
or in the academic field of education
are saying criticism of dr jill biden is
fair
because her dissertation was crap
there's a bigger picture here
that exists on the right and it's been
growing over the last
some odd years a flash point was when
former
republican senator rick santorum said
college is
liberal indoctrination and let me see if
i can sort of lay it out
one of the laughable things that
happened yesterday at this event
by a turning point usa which we covered
is that an incoming republican
congresswoman defiantly said
i will go and debate any professor at
any college
hold on what do you mean debate any
professor like you would debate an
astronomy professor about the planets
you'll debate a chemical engineering
professor about chemical engineering
what do you mean you'll debate any
professor and what i'm guessing she was
implying is she would debate any
professor about politics
but it's this arrogance and perspective
that's become a viru it's like a mind
virus
and it's the same sort of delusion
that's taking place with dr jill biden
this is similar to when people evaluate
the merits of dr
jill biden's dissertation without any
knowledge that would allow them to do
that people who have never been to
college
or people with college degrees in an
unrelated topic random bloggers
everybody gets to evaluate the merits of
dr jill biden's
doctoral dissertation this is very
common on the right
the idea that really you just learn
opinion at college
and mostly it's liberal opinion liberal
professors
giving liberal opinions uh and then the
students take the liberal opinions and
they repeat them
science is liberal they believe or infer
rather than an empirical process and
there's a dunning-kruger aspect to it
where they so misunderstand what college
is and what empiricism is and what
science is
that they don't know that there's a
difference between having an opinion
about what the tax rate should be
and empiricism and the scientific method
that
they end up lacking the capacity to
understand what is happening in college
and to even critique it in a credible
way that's how they end up thinking
it's merely liberal nonsense i can show
up and debate any professor
and i can determine whether dr jill
biden's doctoral dissertation
is meritorious or not but in any case
good for chris wallace sort of kind of
softly alluding
during his interview with white house
press secretary incoming white house
press secretary
gensaki that some of the dr joe biden
nonsense
has actually been happening on fox news
itself